hey hey don't my name is Samuel Leeds
thank you so much for tuning in to this
property investment Channel today I'm
gonna be answering your loaded questions
that come up on the YouTube channel so I
hope you find these really interesting
and the first question that came up
which is by a guy called mr. Salim he
said do you think there'll be a time
when there are too many people investing
in property and it's just not worth it
or do you think they'll be always enough
for everyone to invest in great question
so what am I think about that oh I don't
think there'll ever be a time when
property investing will not be lucrative
I think there'll be a time when you have
to maybe change strategies so rent to
rent might work really well when there's
lots of landlords with properties that
are tired and struggling and you think I
can give them a guaranteed rent and put
tenants in it's great if there's lots of
proper single lapse and single let's are
over saturate it never ones behind
single that's then you could come in and
you could buy a hey CH mo it's or
everything in life and in business is
all about supply and demand so it's
about saying you know what's the demand
what's the supply and the bottom line is
is that this planet isn't getting any
bigger and there's an overpopulation of
people and there's a shortage of houses
and that's going to always be the case
particularly in England like in the UK
we're a very small island so the fact
that there is people literally fighting
to come into this country and we've got
a massive housing crisis owning houses
is only is only it's only good
neighbourhood think is everybody wanting
to do that no they're not people in fact
there's more people now renting and just
get because the thing is on my youtube
channel
okay I'm teaching be financially free
create your own economy be a property
investor like that's what I'm teaching
and helping people do but the thing is
the government and the mass of education
and the media are teaching that message
that teaching work hard get a good job
have security
don't go into debt like that teaching
this and this is what's mainstream so
will there ever be a time when the
financial my financial freedom message
gets to a point where everyone's
financially free and is that it is that
even possible well I hope it does happen
and I think it is possible because
because ah the way the way my mind is
wired is I don't see it as there's only
so much money in the world and when
someone comes along and gets some money
then they're taking it away from the
rest that's a common mystic viewpoint
whereas I'm a capitalist which says that
when you take money you exchange it with
value and that value is going to be able
to mean someone else good so I don't I
don't I don't think competitively I
think collaboratively now sure within
the property industry in any business
strategies techniques do you get
oversaturated and you but when one
strategy becomes oversaturated that
creates a problem and then little
there's an entrepreneur you've got to
find a solution for that problem make
money doing something slightly slightly
out so you can always tweak it and
always make money so I am very very own
people say to me you know I do you think
you're just training up your competition
absolutely not in fact I've made I've
made hundreds and hundreds of thousands
of pounds maybe even millions off the
back of joint venture agreements and
doing business with my success students
so I teach people to do property and
then they become financially free but
then they make me money because we work
together and stuff like that's how I see
it so I hope that answers that question
but it was it was a great question I've
also got sm3 says ice only if you wanted
to do BRR which is buy refurbish
refinance on a single net what kind of
mortgage would you use in the initial
purchase two-year five year fixed or
another okay if you're wanting to do buy
refurbish refinance the whole point of
the strategy is that you buy a house you
then refurbish it to add value to the
house and then you refinance it you get
a new mortgage on the property and you
pull out most or all of them
initial money that you put in so it's a
way of recycling your cash from my
property purchase and if you do this
right you can just buy unlimited amount
of houses for free the only thing is
normally you don't manage to pull out
all your money just pull most of it out
but if you're doing this know you you
should not use a 2 or a 5 year fixed
mortgage you should either use cash so
your own cash because if you buy a
property and you buy it with a mortgage
say if you buy a house and you put down
75% by telling mortgage and then you
refurbish it you can't let me mortgage
it because if you're fixed in a normal
body to let mortgage you can't refinance
it so you're you're leaving your money
in the deal so if you buy cash you put
down your own hard-earned cash and then
refurb it then you can get a mortgage on
it and you can put your money out so
buying it cash is the way to do it if
you haven't got the cash what do you do
either used someone else's cash or what
it won't like what most of my students
do is they just use 2 bridging loan so a
bridging loan is like a short-term loan
so when you borrow it's the same as a
mortgage but you borrow the money for it
you pay more interest but you do over a
deliberate short term so typically a
bridging loan you'll you'll borrow money
for between 4 and 12 months so you might
buy the house for a hundred thousand
pounds and you might put down a little
bit of your own money but the majority
of that hundred thousand pounds is on a
short sale bridging loan then the refurb
you can get a hundred percent financed
on a refurb development so you'll then
get another bridging loan or you use the
same loan but with an extended amount
sometimes bridging companies will give
you a loan and they'll give it you
almost installments isn't when you need
it for like for a refurb for instance
then when you've bought it and you've
added the value and you've done that
with a bridging loan you'll be paying
around about their expensive 1% a month
on a bridging loan that's why you don't
want a bridging loan for years but for
six looks enough time to buy it do the
workup it might only be three months
then you get a new mortgage at a higher
value the maximum value which will be a
buy-to-let standard mortgage this will
be more like three or four percent
interest and then all that the mortgage
that they give you you'll use the
mortgage to pay off the bridging finance
company so that's how you financially
structure they buy refurbish refinance
deal I hope that makes sense if it
hasn't and you've got more questions on
that
just just comment below okay so g-star
186 - hi Samuel love your videos using
your advice from YouTube it's I'm
finding a load of properties which have
in the description sitting tenant yeah
boy sometimes it will say tenant in
stitcher but that's cool whilst this
could be a good thing what rights do
they have and can this give you problems
down the line ok good question I think I
might learn to this before one of the
early videos sitting tenants are not a
bad thing if you want tenants like that
so if you're buying a house for 60,000
pounds and there's a tenants inside
paying five fifth day and they're good
tenants
there's no point buying the house and
then kicking them out not kicking them
out but buying the house and tell them
that your solicitor that you want to buy
empty so forcing them out of the
property just to their remarket the
property and say we're looking for
tenants to pay five fifty like there's
no point you'd be better off to buy the
house and leave the tenants in there and
then day one of completion you getting
rent from a nice good tenant now if you
do that you just need to make sure that
the tenants of good tenants you need to
make sure that they're on a proper ast
contract so that when you buy it it's
the solicitor knows and the management
company knows that you're buying again
the contract is correct but if they're
good tenants and you just want normal
tenants like that then it's a good thing
it's a bad thing if they tell us about
all know if they're bad but if you're
buying the house and you want to turn it
into an HMO then you want to make sure
that you buy the house with no tenants
but if you're just buying it to rent out
and there's already good turns renting
it yeah it's a good thing so hub balance
is question buddy okay
Victoire Feb RIA says Sammie 115 years
old Wow
I can't believe that we have 15 you're
watching this channel it's just
incredible
just finished secondary school been
watching your video sometime now how
long since you were like eleven sometime
now
really books around well good for you
man I've got no money living with
parents the ordinary 15 year old model
there's nothing ordinary about you if
you're 15 and you're watching all of my
videos and you're reading wealth books
don't say you're ordinary because you
really are not ordinary at all I have no
interest in a nine-to-five job good what
are all the tips not some geez Wow you
would give to this person what would you
do and how would you begin
I've really enjoyed your videos the
energy is different than others thanks
so much Victor listen my tip feed but I
is you just need to become valuable so
you're 15 years old
you've got a long long life ahead of you
which is awesome I would focus on being
really valuable so what I mean by that
when you're sweat you're smart if you
understand property if you understand
the business if you know how to find a
deal and what investment areas are good
and how to work out the return on
investment and you get to know the
management companies in the area which
you can do a 15 do you know why because
the market doesn't discriminate there's
there's there's the market doesn't
discriminate the marketplace only cares
about what value you can bring so you
can do there's no excuses so if if you
continue learning about property and
getting yourself in there and become you
should just say I Victoire want to
become as valuable as possible to the
property investment marketplace and that
could even be working for people for
free
finding tenants and renting out people's
rooms for free like just become valuable
to the people in this market place in
this industry ask them what they want
find a state agent in your local area or
an investor in your local area or a
building company and say how could I
bring value to you guys you know can I
help can I offer my services for free
and become like a sponge and when you do
that and you and you become valuable if
imagine if you go get a job for it
estate agents and you work for them for
free or if you're working for investors
finding deals for the
and helping them work out the return on
investment and filling their property
filling their rooms like and you'll
doing that for free just add value and
then after a year you say you know what
I don't want to eat for free anymore if
you want me to do the service you can
now pay me this much because I think
that's how much value is worth it isn't
they'll pay of course they will because
you've become valuable so that were my
big thing I'd focus it's becoming really
valuable and the money the money always
follows the value Albert Einstein says
don't try and be successful try and be
valuable and then the money will all it
has to follow it can't not fine so
rather than giving you all the tips I
have about property investing on the
planet just become valuable have the
helps I can Matthew facer live in the
series Samuel been subscribed for around
half the year now was wondering your
opinion on the lifetime is a and whether
it was a good option for savings I'm a
student and wish to operate real estate
as a form of passive income in a few
years however don't want to tie all my
money down in a lifetime i sir since
that can only be used for property you
intend to live in any thoughts yep don't
do it I would be I would not put my
money into into something like a knife
sir where it's locked away because if
your money is locked away
it's just shrinking and your money in
the bank is come money is completely
useless if it's just stored
unless it's invested that's when it
becomes useful so I would just put every
single penny that I have into myself and
into my investment business so I'd be
educating myself at the point I'd be I'd
be I'd be I would not I would I don't
believe in saving up money
I believe in just investing in property
and then that way the money that you
make in passive income you can do what
you want with that you can spend that
you can live live the life you want on
that but saving saving money is just an
old and old mindset and Isis are
terrible so that's just my opinion okay
what we got next deep and deep M says I
have a burning question please please
please give me some advice if you want
if I were to buy
a property cash how much discount would
I be able to get are there any sort of
standard and how would you approach the
agent would you tell them straight away
before viewing or would you bring it up
later in the negotiation thanks a lot
for your time okay so there's no right
or wrong answer for this there's no if
you're a cash buyer you always get 10%
you can get no money you can get no
discount or you can get a 50% discount
it just depends on the seller so you if
the seller is really motivated and they
need they need their money now and they
want to sell fast and you come along
there's a cash buyer and you say look
here's my money in my bank I'm just
going to be buying this place cash like
of course that's attractive to the to
the seller so you're likely to be in a
position where you can bar you can
negotiate and you can get a mark in
property for sure but in this case I
would just be I'll be upfront with the
agent I would just I would ring the
agent and I would give them I would give
them your preferred deposit I would say
hey hi my name is Samuel EADS and I'm
looking to buy properties outright for
cash but I'm looking to work with
motivated sellers that want to get a
fast sale so that I can get a little bit
of a bargain do you have anything on the
market or anything on your books at the
moment and if they get it if there are
other cats interested in you know that
you're a useful person to our network
because sometimes we do get properties
or sellers like that then I wanted to
say listen you know what would it would
it help if I can send you an email with
my ID and my proof of proof of funds and
then you can keep me posted if you get
any just I would definitely turn upfront
because if you just go and view loads of
houses and then put forward lots of
offers and go I'm a catch by dog for you
in that instance I'll put all your cards
on the table up front for sure and it's
just gonna it's just going to save you
time doing that and it's also going to
save the agent time and for sure but but
yeah there's another thing if you're I
wouldn't be a cash buyer unless you're
planning on buying for cash to then add
value and refinance you don't want to be
buying cash and just leaving big massive
lump sums in properties because your
return is gonna be so bad you always
want to leverage but nothing wrong with
buying cash as long as you don't leave
the cash in the house
all right last question this is from
Steve Mitch hi Samuel my question is
about securing deals as a property
sorcerer through an estate agent say
you've been you say you've seen the
property on Rightmove and phone the
agent do you be up front and tell them
you're a sorcerer with potentially
interested investors but won't be buying
the property yourself no I wouldn't
because if you're an agent and you say
hey I'm a sorcerer
they're not potentially got some
interested investors they are not going
to take you seriously at all
and most estate agents don't deal with
people like that
they mean there might be some that don't
but on the whole they don't and the
reason they don't is because there's so
many investors or deal sources that
haven't got investors and they're just
the time wasters there's people that go
to estate agents and they're put in
cheeky offers you know twenty percent
below market value on everything and
then the estate agent will say oh this
person's just said yes and then use the
deal source or like yes but you haven't
got the money and you haven't got anyone
that'll buy the deal and then what
happens is you have to just waste the
estate agents time spend a few days
trying to sell this deal and then you
can't and then you have to decide to
this stage and I'm really sorry I can't
and then you've wasted people's time
you've got people's hopes up you've
you're messing with people's money this
is what this is what bad deal sources do
and because of that estate agents have
almost like bad deal sources have given
a bad reputation to all your sources so
the estate agents don't want to work
with deal sources like anymore which
sucks
so what I'll tell you I normally do but
please only use this if you have been
trained properly and you know what
you're doing like if you've come on like
programs and you're a you're a you're a
compliant a deal saw so you know the
steps and everything then use this
strategy I'm about to teach you but if
you if you don't if you haven't been on
any of my training I'll tell you this
anyway but please don't use this because
you're going to end up just doing more
damage so what I do is I put the offer
forward as if it's me
so I'll say hey I'll offer 80,000 and
then when they accept or if if they
accept yeah they've accepted please the
first thing they're gonna want is
they're gonna want to see my ID and my
proof of funds and what's this the
details so the static who says hey good
news and this tension doesn't really
know me I'm just I'm just someone they
just booked a viewing on a house I've
had to give them my name and stuff so
they they know my name but they don't
they haven't got relationship with me at
this point
so they also they'll ring me up hey
congratulations they accept it eighty
thousand pounds please can you send us
your proof of proof of funds mortgage
details listed details for one day I'll
say yeah no problem I'll get that over
to you tomorrow then
I will sell the property like but when I
sell a property and when my student to
sell properties they sound like that I
mean some of my students they'll send an
email and they'll have the money in
their bank for the property within like
15 minutes it's that fast they'll have
someone respond on email saying I want
to secure that house I'm ready to pay
your fee within 30 seconds it's that
powerful when you have a an investor
list who are ready so you send that
email out there let's say Joe Bloggs
wants to buy the house I'll say to Joe
Bloggs
Joe Bloggs I'm gonna need your photo ID
mortgage in principle proof of funds etc
etc he'll send that to me all I will
then send an email to the estate agent
and say hi Sarah from Dickson's estate
agents and then I'll just say the
property is not going to be going in my
name it's going to be going in the name
of Joe blocks please see attached his
blah blah blah blah blah bum bum bum bum
bum and this is his contact number now
at this point the estate agent might
realize oh hmm is this person a sorcerer
or they might just think that Joe Bloggs
is your business partner like or your or
your your husband or like anything like
they're at know who Joe is but what they
do know about Joe is they know that
they've got Joe's proof of funds
they've got his mortgage in principle
the glaze solicited details and they
know that he's wanting to buy the house
for 80 which has been agreed it's all
happened fast so at this point the
estate agent isn't gonna go oh oh whoa
hey hold on that they don't care
because they know that well they've got
they're gonna make this sale because
they've got all the proof of funds
they've got the deal agreed they're
going to make that money so they're okay
at that point once the property goes
through and completes all them bring the
agent again if I send another good
property and I'll say hey I've seen this
property which is also good you've
worked with me before it was Joe blocks
ended up buying this property and then
they'll probably think oh you're a
sorcerer but you're a sorcerer just make
them money you're a sorcerer who isn't
gonna mess them around now the reason is
it don't use this unless you've actually
been through my training is because this
could backfire not backfire but if you
try and use the strategy but you haven't
got the training one of the first things
that we teach you when we teach you how
to sell bills our advanced training is
we teach you how to get a list of hot
investors ready to buy from you and how
to prime them so when you're looking to
properties you know exactly what they
want to buy also when you put offers
forward you're going to put the part of
the pot of the puzzle is you're going to
put forward if would offer so before you
agree to buy it for 80,000 you're gonna
say you know if I was to say 80 what you
didn't let say and then they're gonna
say to you you know what then except a
day so you haven't formally put falling
off it yet then I'm gonna prime these
guys my investors I'm gonna be like hey
guys I've got this property I think I'll
be able to wrap it about eighty thousand
what are you thinking if the response is
good and then like yeah and there's a
few people are interested then I'll put
for my formal offer of a day they'll
accept bang I'll say it within fifteen
seconds because so it's really important
they have the order right now listen if
you are a bidding watcher of my youtube
videos and you haven't been down to any
of my training programs just do it
because the way the what happens on my
training programs is very different to
what you see on YouTube because we
actually
do stuff like on YouTube I can't say to
you right make this call you know find
this deal how did it go I can't interact
with you in that way
so in on YouTube I'll put as much as I
can out for free but really you've got
you've got to come on on some of the
training then the good news is I do run
some training for free so what I'll do
is I'll put a link in this video
property - investors go to UK where
hopefully fingers crossed there'll be a
link on that link you'll get to book on
for a two day training program with me
personally and if you click on the link
and you can see that there's a training
available with me just booked it because
it's rare that that happens because
normally it's like sold out or whatever
so that's my advice I hope that was
really helpful guys I absolutely love
doing this also if you don't subscribe
to the channel or if you're subscribed
but you haven't got the notification
Bell Bell ticked do that as well because
the more subscribers that I have means
the more views that I get which inspires
me and encourages me to do more content
so you know the more views that I get
the better the content would be the
better the guests will be now that Grant
Cardone Robert Kiyosaki Martyn Roberts
from homes under the hammer BBC but I've
had some really cool guests in and the
reason I'm able to get these people on
the show is because I say to them you
know hey Robert Kiyosaki I've got like
90,000 subscribers I've got a really
awesome engaged audience do you want to
come on the show and hear and agree to
it because of you so because of you guys
it enables me to get to meet and know
some really cool people so I really
appreciate you guys subscribing and
watching and I appreciate your questions
just support hope to see you at a
training program real soon and until
next time see you then
[Music]